well the earthquakes that we have seen
that have impacted both turkey and Syria
uh at a scale that we've not seen for
quite some time when I when I heard
about it early this morning I
immediately contacted my Turkish
opposite number to express our
condolences and to give an offer of
assistance and in response to Turkish
requests we have deployed a search and
rescue team who will be leaving soon and
should be on the ground shortly to give
the Turkish authorities the help that
they need to try and save as many lives
as possible and do we yet know of any
British fatalities or injuries and we do
we expect there to be any over the
coming days well with an earthquake of
this magnitude we sadly have already
seen many thousands of people die we
don't know the full extent of the
injuries or fatalities and sadly they're
likely to grow over the coming days at
this stage we are not aware of any
British fatalities but of course it's
too easy it's just far too early for us
to say that won't be the case and can
you tell us a bit about the support that
Britain is providing and whether that
will be increased over the coming days
well with a situation like this of
course timeliness is of the essence so
we have deployed a large search and
rescue team with state-of-the-art
life-saving equipment they will be
deploying to Turkey very soon they
should be leaving today and deploying
soon as they arrive with Syria of course
the situation is more complicated but we
have given many years of support to the
white helmets who of course are experts
in search and rescue will be working
through our un Partners on the ground
and we have increased funding and
allocated funding specifically in
response to this situation okay thank
you much can I just ask you one question
on something slightly different
um Liz truss of course former Ally of
yours has been doing a bit of a
publicity push
um can I just get your response to that
and I guess what what you think she
wants to get out of this well look what
uh what Liz has written and what she
wants to do is a question I think best
directed towards Liz at the moment I'm
very much focused on providing the
support that the Turkish government need
to help save lives in response to these
terrible earthquakes and work with our
International Partners in Syria to do
likewise